[Music]  let me give you some advice  you can't care about anyone else  everyone else is an  obstacle you care what an obstacle wants  or feels you're dead  if i'd cared about anyone or thing i  might have died  you have the talent whether you have the  killer  instinct is the big question  hmm  she thought she owned everyone that's  foolish unhinged  well you're fired why are you speaking i  think you mixed me  but there's something about poetic  justice that's just so  poetic you won't admit you love me  and so however  get her this doesn't have to be a scene  it really really does  i'd like to remind you all that i'm  doing this in heels  what was your name cruella if you can  [Music]  you have a bit of an extreme side yes  darling  what fun that is  she stole my dogs  i guess you must hate her she has made  it me or her  and i choose me  don't worry there's lots more bad things  coming perhaps  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  perhaps  [Music]  bye